the police will have been glad the
weekend was over the sunbathers were out
but there was none of the chaos of
yesterday one hundreds had to be turned
away from this Barcelona Beach to avoid
overcrowding still if these people were
heeding local government advice they
wouldn't be on the sand at all but at
home going out for only essential
reasons sk k la gente SE a mark on tnt
okay only article into a gotten to casa
is totally meant in quarantine the size
is equal to Kazuto para Wan open-circuit
I can't see any la medida que so they
went o mad no the very exited Nestor
ending on problem an extra traction of
the beach is it's the one place in
Barcelona you don't have to wear a face
covering elsewhere in the city and right
across Catalonia masks are now required
when you're out in public people are at
least adhering to that order masks now
nestled amongst the tourist gifts on
Barcelona's usually packed lazarum plus
the visitors are far fewer now as
Catalonia grapples to control kovat
numbers but some Britons have taken this
moment to come in case things get worse
just a small window I booked it pretty
much at the last minute I thought if I
don't come now and more spikes happen
and there's more lockdown I don't know
when I'd come I heard the cases were
rising I actually thought should I go or
not but then you know as long as
measures are taken and people wear masks
I thought you know we can't stop living
but many are not so confident some have
already cancelled their trips businesses
are struggling and desperate to get the
visitors back for the secretary of
tourism in Barcelona these are difficult
times we asked him if British tourists
should be worried about coming to
Catalonia yo creo que no no mas que por
viajar in la paga Inglaterra
yo creo que no I you know citavi digamos
grab a parent arista porque los pocos de
cabeza esta muy local asados sorry most
understand creo que un problema the
greater local
nor fate miserable character and
touristical but if the number of Kovac
cases continue to rise Catalonia will
struggle to present a positive image to
international travelers there's already
talk of France closing its border with
Spain because of the number of cases in
Barcelona for now a total lockdown has
been avoided here there are no
guarantees that state of affairs will
last
Michell turf at Sky News Barcelona